yeah so you think you can't just go
become a great actor based on just your
instincts
do you do you need that's a hard
that's a tough question right it's a
really tough question i think that you
know for me
and i you know i mean i the i'm not
saying something like revolutionary i
think if you look at
at my work for example like you see it
right there
um
there is for me the construction of
character is really important
and finding
who that person is
um and and that
voice and
body and movement and rhythm and pace
and all of those things
um
help to make up who that character is
i'm creating yeah there's
just as valuable you know like
i mean harrison ford for example
harrison ford is spoiler alert i'm
looking because he's got a strategy
right here
he's not he's not transformative right
right he's he's essentially harrison
ford right like right i mean he's not
he's not he's not brando or
you know de niro or you you know and not
that but he's saying that better he's
incredibly effective but it's about so
like
does he just have incredible instincts i
don't know i don't i don't know him
personally i don't know what his process
is right
but you know um
but for me it's about it's about using
all of those tools that i have now
to try to
completely
invent in every way who this character
is how they're the same as i am and how
they're different so you're doing all
these plays in college right yes and
what happens after were you aspiring to
do film and television or was it theater
something you just wanted to do for the
rest of your life no i was just talking
to somebody actually emmanuel shriki um
on my podcast about this that for me it
was only theater
that was all i and thinking back because
i just had this conversation with her on
the podcast that i
i can't i don't even
film and television never
it just almost wasn't even a something i
thought about wow never i really that's
crazy it just seems to me that every
actor wants to be get an oscar every
actor wants to get a you know it's like
i have to admit like when i was in
college i was watching tarantino movies
and going i like theater but man i want
to do movies i want people to see me i
want i want
yeah i mean
i definitely
i don't know i think for me that was
just not that it wasn't achievable it
was just not something
it was not the path that i was on i
guess
and maybe i just did maybe i just sort
of thought like oh that's for later or
something like
and
um
here's a story i don't think i've ever
told um and harrison ford now it's all
coming back to harrison ford
i had a friend who i met in
chicago in the cheer up program before
my senior year we stayed friends
um and she had moved to la and she was
actually on a television show
um and
um
[Music]
she became very good friends with
calista flockhart's
best friend harrison ford's wife
harrison ford's wife and i
she invited me to come out
to the premiere you could figure out the
date of when this was i'm gonna say it's
circa 1999
or 2000. okay the premiere of i think a
midsummer night's dream is she in
mid-summer midsummer night's dream the
movie i believe it's a midsummer night's
dream
let's just forgive you if you're wrong
it was um
invited me to the premiere
and i was at the premiere
and my friend lived around westwood
and so i was staying with her around
westwood
walking through westwood going to coffee
bean
for the first time
the weather was amazing and going to the
premiere and faye dunaway was sitting
right behind me
and i
truly i that for me was like
oh i like it here
i want to be here now really that was it
that feeling that was the it was like oh
no this is i belong here and
i grew up in atlanta so that was my
homie i was born raised
through high school that was my home and
i as i was doing i was in you know
dallas and then minneapolis like i said
i was kind of based in minneapolis and i
was traveling around and doing theater
in all of these places i was like a
regional theater actor so i would go
where the work was and
um
but i was i never had a home for for
sure i never had a home and i visited
here on that trip and it's such a cliche
now right it's like well yeah you were
at like a humongous premiere you know
they rented out in westwood
you know like an acre of land and turned
it into the forest it was midsummer
night's dream right yeah was mid-seminar
99 in 99 that's this [ __ ] steel trap
of a memory right there in 1999
midsummer night
and so it's like oh you're out of
premiere and there's fey done away like
of course
of course you're gonna be seduced by it